[Music]
many countries around the world are
easing their measures to curb the
coronavirus pandemic
with more liberties and fewer
restrictions again spain is one of them
and so is south africa
hopes are rising here that the pandemic
will soon become endemic promising an
end to restrictions so how might kovat
19 become endemic and what would that
mean our topic on this week's coveted 19
special welcome
[Music]
today is an important day for cipello
ghalivani two years ago financial
problems and the pandemic forced him to
close his bar and restaurant in cape
town's kailicha township but now he's
finally reopening
povet has taught us a lot of things that
you need to put your eggs in different
baskets and also
you need to try and think outside the
box because i mean
for me i don't cast the storm
from whatever bad situation that i mean
i always look for positive things
better things that i can do instead of
complaining
after nearly two years most lockdown
restrictions were lifted including a
nightly curfew tourists have once again
been pouring into the country there had
been mass cancellations following the
discovery of the omicron variant
life is slowly getting back to normal
here in cape town with decreasing
numbers in new covet infections data
from south africa suggests although
omicron is much more infectious the
amount of people that were admitted to
hospitals was much lower than during
previous waves many here are hoping that
we're seeing the beginning of the end of
the pandemic i so wish that
i won't even hear about the the name
covet
that's what we're
wishing for it's very nice to see
everyone just going out and about
relaxing
going outside i mean we've been locked
locked out in our houses for how long
now i hope that omicron is actually the
final stage of this virus to see such
enjoyment this is such happiness i'm so
happy that the business is booming
people can start making money our
country is officially open when lost did
i see such a
such hecticness and business i'm glad
that we can get to come here and enjoy
many scientists are also optimistic
despite the low vaccination rate
virologist wolfgang preiser says that
many south africans had already been
infected with the coronavirus before the
omicron wave hospital data showed that a
prior coronavirus infection or
vaccination provides protection against
severe illness also with the omicron
variant
when you arrive at a situation like the
one we have here now where nearly
everyone is recovered from an infection
or has been vaccinated then you can
relax
and of course it's summer here during
much of the fourth wave here our schools
were on holiday
in europe the school holiday was much
shorter school is starting again
companies that took an annual holiday
are back at work too and of course it's
winter when people spend much more time
together indoors
those are major differences that's why
you can't just expect things in europe
to go exactly the way they have in south
africa
in south africa prizer hopes that the
pandemic could become endemic as with
other coronaviruses if most of the
population has a basic immunity from
previous infection or vaccination
i still have hope that we'll be able to
avoid the need for regular booster shots
let's say that everyone is fully
vaccinated and boosted and perhaps also
gets an omicron specific booster during
the coming year
[Music]
let's also say we don't suddenly find
ourselves confronted with a nasty
surprise in the form of another new
variant
then we might be able to maintain a
decent level of immunity with regular
reinfections
no one wants to think about more
mutations right now in the milk
restaurant and bar certainly not
ownership or
he already has big plans and wants to
expand to other cities he believes that
the prospects for south africa once
again look good
and what about germany and europe here
the rate of new infections has hit
record levels
tens of thousands are catching covet 19
and passing it on
we seem to be at its mercy and we're
sick of it all
here in the newsroom talk revolves
mainly around one question
[Music]
will life ever return to normal
lockdowns contact restrictions schools
opening schools closing and a series of
new sasko v2 variants each in some ways
worse than the last
when will this pandemic end when will
the virus become endemic and what does
that even mean
that we can go back to our pre-pandemic
ways
nice thought but it's still a pandemic
out there
so let's take a look at where we are
right now
in a pandemic a disease spreads across
national borders and continents
sasko v2 affects the entire
world all pandemics eventually end but
no one can say exactly when the current
one will be over
the spanish flu is an example of an
influenza pandemic that's thought to
have killed between 50 and 100 million
people
it lasted around three years
the seventh cholera pandemic began in
south asia in 1961 and continues to this
day
it leads up to 140 000 death annually
after two years of a non-stop covet 19
pandemic with millions of people dead
and billions more vaccinated recovered
or both there's increasing talk of the
coronavirus becoming endemic
what does that mean
in ancient greek endemus means among the
people so if saskov2 is endemic it's
come to stay
however endemic viruses are not equally
present everywhere all the time
although endemic viruses circulate
non-stop within particular populations
the number of infections can fluctuate
based for example on the seasons
other cold viruses demonstrate this
winter time is cold season this will not
change next winter or the winter after
that it's predictable
malaria is an example of an endemic
infectious disease that's a major
problem particularly in certain african
regions
and malaria is also a good example of a
popular misconception
that an endemic pathogen is
automatically a less dangerous pathogen
it isn't
according to the world health
organization malaria killed
627 000 people in 2020 alone
on the other hand there are several
endemic coronaviruses that usually only
cause fairly harmless cold-like symptoms
so what will happen with saskov2
the omicron variant of the virus has
many people hoping that in the future
the majority of covet infections will be
mild
however we don't know what variant might
be just around the corner
what is clear though is that we'll have
to continue to live with sasko v2 in the
future
nonetheless some european countries
including denmark spain and the uk have
already decided to roll back antivirus
measures
most are aware that it's something of an
experiment along the lines of let's see
what happens
we take a look at what's happening in
the spanish capital madrid
[Music]
here in madrid cafes are full to the
brim with people enjoying the afternoon
sun
no one seems to be worried that a guest
at the next table could have coveted
a number of coronavirus restrictions
have already been rolled back here
we have to free ourselves of this fear
you can't
just as we have with the flu and with
other viruses
this relaxed mood is partly due to the
success of spain's vaccination program
more than 80 percent of the population
has received at least two jabs and
hospitalization rates are also on the
decline
that's also why the spanish government
has announced it's planning to lift a
series of other restrictions that
includes ramping down coronavirus
testing and easing quarantine rules
a flu instead of a deadly pandemic this
is how prime minister sanchez wants to
treat the coronavirus in the future and
he sees himself as a pioneer in europe
but there are also critics that say that
it's too early for such experiments they
point out that many spanish clinics
continue to work at their limit
one of spain's leading coronavirus
experts isabel sola is also urging
caution she's a researcher at spain's
national center of biotechnology
we must stay prepared for surprises
the way the virus will develop is
something we can't predict
the virus wants to keep spreading
so that might mean that infections will
become less severe over time but the
exact opposite could also be true
for the moment many in spain seem to
welcome the easing of restrictions
almost two years into the pandemic
they're ready to believe that the danger
has passed
many experts in germany are also urging
caution dw reporter stephanie zobel
spoke with professor hayo zape the
bremen-based epidemiologist has earned
the reputation of being a voice of calm
in the pandemic storm
thanks for talking to us many hope that
covid19 will become endemic and all of
the suffering under the pandemic will
end would that be the case
endemic doesn't mean that it's entirely
over or that it's no longer a threat
depending on virus mutations the
situation could change and covet could
become an epidemic again and spread at a
higher rate again even if this doesn't
happen even if the infection rates don't
suddenly surge
an endemic disease still means people
will still be getting infected and
getting sick
we'll have to take appropriate measures
to deal with that and make sure that our
hospitals can cope
so our precautions our public health and
hygiene measures will still be a part of
everyday life in an endemic scenario
is an endemic sars virus less dangerous
you could say it might be less dangerous
yes but that would take two things first
the biological severity would have to be
lower meaning there would be fewer
serious cases and lower mortality rates
you'd see that change over time through
biological evolution
and second our response to the virus is
also a factor
that includes the immunity we achieve
through effective vaccination campaigns
as well as the immunity achieved through
infection
and third there are also various counter
measures like social distancing wearing
masks and so on
all of those would help level out the
infection rates
can we help the pandemic become an
endemic scenario
yes we can of course first of all by
building up our immunity especially by
way of high vaccination rates and high
rates everywhere
[Music]
that's how we might be able to achieve
this endemic state
by making sure that our immunity is
robust enough to prevent sudden epidemic
outbreaks
vaccination is key
is it possible to maintain an endemic
state in a globalized world
that's a good question one of the big
preconditions for that would be
eliminating these huge drastic
disparities in immunization rates around
the world
that's why the world health organization
for example is constantly emphasizing
that we need vaccine equity high
vaccination rates in all countries
distributing vaccines as evenly as
possible will help us achieve this
endemic state
when a few countries have extremely high
vaccination rates but other countries
have very low rates that's where the
conditions are right for the virus to
continue to spread and mutate
that's what helps create problems which
in a global context could lead to a
resurgence of the epidemic over and over
which would sweep around the world
what other scenarios are there
there are several alternative scenarios
one would be to actually defeat to
eliminate the coronavirus take china for
example which is sticking to its
zero-covered policy they're pursuing a
policy of keeping covid out of their
country in the short term and especially
in the long term
it's easy to see why that's not a
particularly pragmatic approach they
would have to steer clear of all sorts
of global activities or build very high
walls to keep the virus out that strikes
me as very difficult as an illusion in
human history there are only a few
viruses we've managed to eradicate
we did it with smallpox with a global
vaccination program but that's one of
the rare
thank you too
now to dw science editor derek williams
who's been following developments and
answering your questions since the onset
of the pandemic
[Music]
this week youtube user juan pedro sierra
asked why did the spanish flu pandemic
end even though they never developed
treatments or a vaccine
in 1918 just as humanity began to to
stagger towards the end of what
at that point
was the most destructive conflict in
human history
a new flu virus appeared that would
later be called the spanish flu now
that name was inaccurate since the
disease didn't show up in spain first it
was only the first place that newspapers
began to report on it
the virus that caused the new flu was a
subtype called
h1n1
it's thought that during the pandemic
that rolled over the world in the
following couple of years around
one in three people were infected by the
pathogen
we don't have records good enough to
make
exact calculations of the destruction
that it caused but but most estimates
say the virus claimed between 50
and 100 million victims
that would have been around one in 25
people on the planet at the time
then three years into the pandemic the
spanish flu
seemed to fade away
without any clear explanation
it just sort of trailed off
no one at the time really knew why
now
experts postulate that it was because
without vaccines
that's how long it took to acquire a
measure of global herd protection
through infection when enough people
grew immune enough to the pathogen
to stop spreading it to others
transmission sputtered and died
or did it really um that's a really
interesting aspect of the narrative
experts say because
even though mass death due to the
pandemic ended in the early 1920s
the virus that caused it didn't just
disappear instead
they think the immunity developed by
large swaths of the population
drove the pathogen to mutate and it
mutated into less deadly forms
in fact researchers who analyzed genomes
in flu viruses that circulate today
have identified genetic similarities
that link them
to the h1n1 virus that first appeared in
1918.
that original virus
has been sequenced from from lung
samples taken from people
who died from the virus back then in
that sense
the spanish flu virus is is still with
us today it's just evolved to be less
virulent but
it also occasionally then evolves
further and can throw out
deadlier variants and strains though at
least so far
never any as as deadly as its distant
ancestor
[Music]
and now for some animals with
superpowers such as sharks
camels
and their cousins in south america
alpacas
scientists have found neutralizing
antibodies to the coronavirus and its
variants in these species could animals
help bring an end to the pandemic that
probably began in an animal
at first glance this south american
alpaca looks like an ordinary animal
but scientists think it could help us
fight the coronavirus pandemic
a herd of 19 alpacas are living on the
campus of austral university in valdivia
southern chile
biochemist alejandro rojas is conducting
research working with the alpacas
[Applause]
this male alpaca is called buddha he's
developed neutralizing antibodies
against a number of covid19 variants
including omicron
the scientists first vaccinated the
alpaca with surface proteins from the
covid19 virus
then they took a blood sample and found
nanobodies that can neutralize saskov2
viruses
nanobodies are much smaller than normal
antibodies
their structure is also less complex and
they're quite easy to reproduce using
yeast cultures for example
nanobodies are only produced by
camellids so alpacas llamas camels and
dromedaries and by sharks
even before the pandemic began rojas and
his team founded and publicized an
initiative aimed at combating emerging
viruses
but they didn't have any animals to work
with
until
one of them was buddha then we have
dilgo tara and pedro
they haven't just produced antibodies to
fight sars kobe 2 like buddha but
against other viruses too like nipa
virus and hendra virus pedro here for
example
the research doesn't harm the alpacas
once a year they're vaccinated by vets
who then take a small sample of blood
the animals are cared for by
veterinarian teresa pinto
they like pets
they eat out of our hands we take care
of them and love them
at first they wouldn't come near us
but now they're no longer stressed by
our presence
we treat them very well
yapaka's well-being is extremely
important to us
in valdivia in southern chile at austral
university's laboratory for medical
biotechnology
rohas and his team have patented 30
nanobodies that directly target sars
cove 2 viruses
now they want to use the alpacas
nanobodies to develop a drug to treat
covid19
this involves mixing the alpaca
nanobodies with a fragment of a human
antibody so that it is accepted by the
human immune system
the drug could be inhaled or
administered in the form of a nasal
spray or injection
and help to prevent severe or fatal
cases of covid19
but the scientists need financial
support to develop the drug and so far
the chilean government hasn't offered
funding
it's not just about developing an
antiviral therapy for sars kobe too
but also showing that here in a remote
place like southern chile we are capable
of developing a technology that can help
bring a global pandemic under control
the scientists in chile aren't the only
ones researching alpaca nanobodies
there's a similar initiative underway at
the university of san francisco
and in germany the university of bonn
and the max planck institute in
guttington are engaged in nanobody
research
but the scientists here in chile are a
step ahead
one of the big advantages of developing
antibodies from camellids in chile is
that here the alpacas and llamas are in
their natural habitat
at the university campus the alpacas
have their own enclosure covering more
than three hectares of land where
they're free to roam sleep and feed
the scientists haven't just given the
alpacas names they've also discovered
distinct personality traits
buddha is a bit shy
when new people are around he won't eat
out of my hand
he's not so keen on people he doesn't
know
[Music]
they all have different personalities
despite his shyness buddha is quite the
star on social media
he has nearly 17 000 followers on
instagram alone
the alpacas provide an alternative
solution to monoclonal antibodies that
is much cheaper in the coming years
we'll probably see many products
developed in the immune systems of these
animals
with the necessary funding the alpacas
may be able to help us both in this
pandemic and in future ones too
alejandro rojas and his team are
convinced of that
that's all for this week if you have a
question for derek williams write to us
and join us next time for a fresh
edition of our covet 19 special goodbye
for now and take care
[Music]
you